dieses nicht endende corona drama und
vor allem die nicht endenden corona
maßnahmen und immer wieder wird eine
neue zahl gesetzt ein neues ziel gesetzt
und dann dann kommt endlich die
freiheits gestern hat die
bundeskanzlerin
weil wieder so eine zahl genannt 85
prozent der 18 bis 59 jährigen 12 bis
59-jährigen 12 bis 59-jährigen geimpft
haben müssen solchen und 90 prozent der
über 60 jährigen dann ist der anstieg
beherrschbar von diesen im quoten sind
wir noch weit entfernt da also da ist
sie die neue zahl so viele menschen
müssen geimpft werden bei uns im studio
ist jetzt aus unserer
wirtschaftsredaktion autorin nina schenk
freue mich sehr und philipp fiat auf der
chef unseres meinungs- ressort herzlich
willkommen mit dass ihr da seid bevor
wir loslegen wir haben natürlich da
draußen einmal gefragt wie was 85 90
prozent sie ist doch immer 60 prozent
müssten geimpft werden und dann kommt
die freiheit wieder
jetzt also neue zahlen und wir wollten
wissen was halten sie denn davon
die politik hat ja von anfang an gesagt
es wird in deutschland keinen impfzwang
geben jetzt ist aber die ganze zeit die
rede davon dass wir mindestens 85%
geübte in deutschland brauchen um wieder
lockern zu können findest du das ist
angemessen diese zahl
nein nein das finde ich nicht glaube ich
nicht denke mal das schon vorher
gelockert werden durfte ein virus
mutiert das ist jedem bekannt das ist
auch fräulein merkel bekannte sind alles
gebildete menschen
wir müssen jedes jahr grippe impfen wie
sollen wir eine herbe immunität
erreichen ist funktioniert nicht dann
selber auch zweimal geimpft und finde es
eigentlich auch vernünftig wenn erst
eine gewisse quote erreicht wird und
dann eben erst lockerungen eintreten ich
glaube die wenn wir ähnlich erreichen
die 85 prozent also hält es für
realistisch dass wir auf 85 prozent
kommen realistisch muss ich gestehen
glaube ich nicht dafür gibt es einfach
zu viele die derzeit noch dagegen sind
oder so einfach nicht möchten und von
daher finde ich es auch schwierig dann
so eine quote zu setzen die vielleicht
auch gar nicht umsetzbar ist ab wann
sollte denn gelockert werden ab sofort
ist es doch einfach nur noch höher
ein hin und her ich verstehe auch nicht
dass das die leute überhaupt noch
mitmachen so lange wie wir uns alle an
die hygiene regeln halten oder was sehe
ich da eigentlich keine bedenken wir
müssen dann lockern wenn wir allen die
möchten den impfangebot gemacht haben
wobei ich das wort schon gar nicht mehr
hören kann von herrn sparen ist das
unwort des jahres 20 28 aber ich denke
wenn jeder hat eine chance wer sich
impfen zu lassen dann können die anderen
oder die die sich haben impfen lassen
nicht die die sich nicht impfen wollen
mit leiden also mit anderen worten ich
denke dass jetzt zeit für lockerung
gekommen ist im angebot als vorschlag
für das unwort des jahres lassen es
einmal gemeinsam darauf schauen wie es
überhaupt aus jetzt gerade in
deutschland wie viele menschen sind denn
dort geimpft und haben bereits ein pieks
bekommen und haben somit zumindest die
aussicht auf ein bisschen freiheit die
impfquote in deutschland 43 prozent sind
vollständig geimpft haben also beide
pixar bekommen und 58,7 haben zumindest
einen piepser bekommen das heißt 82,4
millionen verabreichte impfdosen gute
werte eigentlich oder eigentlich könnte
man sich über diese werte doch freund
schauen wir einmal noch auf die
täglichen erste und zweite impfung
wir haben jetzt noch mal einfach 43 für
alle die die es noch nicht gehört haben
haben sind vollständig geimpft und 58,7
sind zumindest einmal geimpft also
nochmal zur betonung das sind gute
zahlen es geht voran bei den über 70
jährigen liegt die quote ja auch noch
weitaus höher also auch gerade diese
sehr volatile gruppe ist jetzt
vollständig geschützt gehört bei uns
philipp hof und nina schenk würdest du
hast gestern einen satz geschrieben ich
muss ihn gerade mal raus suchen finden
ihr sich wahrscheinlich selber noch ich
habe ihn mir vor mir stehen weil er auch
so schön fand nahm zwei sitze der
impfstoff gegen korona müsste unser land
frei machen
doch stattdessen verfällt die regierung
immer stärker in einer sprache der
unfreiheit was genau meinst du damit
richtig also der korona impfstoff sollte
uns ja eigentlich von zwei dingen
erlösen erstens von der pandemie selbst
für uns vom virus beschützen und
zweitens natürlich auch von den
einschränkungen aber man merkt dass die
politik zunehmend in eine sprache der
unfreiheit verfällt man hat das von
markus söder gehört ohne impfung keine
freiheit man hat das von jens spahn
gehört die ungeimpften müssten sich
morgen nicht wohnen wenn sie nicht zu
partys eingeladen
werden und gestern hat zum beispiel der
grüne gesundheitsminister von baden
württemberg gesagt es könnte auch sein
dass ungeimpfte am gesellschaftlichen
leben nicht teilnehmen dürften
da frage ich mich wie redet der staat
eigentlich mit uns was glaubt ihr was er
sich rausnehmen kann wie einer der
bürger ist gesagt hat mit dem wir
gesprochen haben
sobald es ein impf angebot für alle
menschen gegeben hat und da sind wir
kurz davor
dann endet die sorgfaltspflicht des
staates dann hat jeder bürger die
freiheit gehabt sich zu entscheiden
möchte er sich impfen lassen oder eben
nicht und dann sollte man es auch den
bürgern überlassen die konsequenzen zu
tragen aber es gibt kein recht des
staates dann weiterhin einschränkungen
aufrecht zu erhalten energie siehst du
erst dann fühlst du dich von so einer
rhetorik fassen
ich finde es unfassbar
sie müssen wirklich mal was gerade
passiert das überhaupt herr söder so was
sag ich würde sogar noch weiter gehen
ich bin jetzt zwei mal geimpft habe die
14 tage überstanden ich möchte sofort
meine grundrechte zurück weil das in
grundrechte die eingeschränkt werden und
es steht dem stark wenn man zweimal
geimpft ist und immun ist einfach nicht
mehr zu diese einzugreifen
warum soll ich noch eine maske tragen
davon fühle ich mich ehrlich gesagt
verarscht es dann ruhig so sagen ich bin
fassungslos darüber
ich möchte gerne heute meine maske
ablegen ich sehe keinen sinn mehr daran
dieses stück stoff zu tragen da ich
zweimal geimpft bin und die immunität
habe und ich kann philipp ehrlich gesagt
nur zustimmen oder langweilige
diskussionen aber so ist wenn du das
jetzt hörst wir brauchen plötzlich 85
prozent hier 90 prozent hier also da
wird schon wieder
eigentlich etwas aufgebaut ein ziel
aufgebaut wird wahrscheinlich nie
erreichen werden um womöglich diese
maßnahmen in unendliche zu verlängern
was was löst das bei dir aus ich finde
es ehrlich gesagt eigentlich gut das wir
anstreben eine hohe impfquote zu haben
impfen ist der weg aus der korona
pandemie raus und wir müssen schaffen
dass möglichst viele geimpft werden das
ist ganz klar ich würde auch wenn wir
dafür werden können fürs impfen werden
aber wie erreichen wir das also eine
impfquote gesetzt wird auch etwas zu
hoch gesetz verbunden mit maßnahmen aber
erst mal gut dass wir sagen viele sollen
geimpft werden die frage ist ja wie
kommen wir da hin
ich bin natürlich komplett gegen eine
impfpflicht das wäre für mich wirklich
mit der schlimmste was man machen könnte
in bezug auf die freiheit ich werde
dafür dass wir
ich beginne incentives zu setzen wenn
wir nach amerika beispielsweise blicken
dort gibt es die imf lotterie es ist
sehr einfach zu impfen ohne es ohne
termin kriegt man sofort die impfung ich
finde in deutschland bin gerade noch der
weg zur impfung vor allem jetzt wo wir
den impfstoff haben viel viel viel zu
sehr noch erschwert mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren